all right theresa
yeah teresa where are you from where'd
you grow up i grew up in los angeles
california
south central south central yes tell me
about your childhood you had both your
parents when you were young
no just my mom just my mom she raised um
she raised seven kids on her own where
was dad uh doing his thing
you know papa was a rolling stone
wherever he laid his hat was his home
yeah yeah and uh how would you describe
your childhood
how would i what big pardon how would
you describe your childhood um
it was it was uh it was pretty good i
mean
you know my mom did what she had to do
to take care of her kids you know
and she believed in if she lay down and
had you she's going to take care of you
you know so
that's what it was pretty good it was
okay
yeah no abuse no no crazy traumatic
events
um well when i was six i got molested so
that led me to a wildlife of uh drugs
and alcohol
and you know being promiscuous and stuff
like that and
at the age of 16 i started uh
prostituting
you know i was using drugs and i i
needed a way to uh
to support my habit so i started
prostituting and um
it led into a wildlife you know of uh
different
different things and run into different
people you know
once once uh this guy tried to rape me
you know and i just had to cut him up
you know i cut his face up and stuff and
you know just had to do what i had to do
to survive he had locked the doors and
it wasn't
he didn't have no thing to open up the
doors yeah and he tried to rape me and
um
i just had to do what i had to do to
survive he had closed put the child
locks on the door so i couldn't get out
the car
and um yeah he it was just all bad you
know he started beating on me and stuff
and i just pulled out my knife
and i just started cutting him up you
know and he opened up the door pretty
fast after i started cutting him up
but uh i had to kick out the window for
him to really open up the doors but that
was one of
my um tragic experiences that i've had
since i've been working the streets
you know and um it's it's it's a wild
world
especially in los angeles california you
know um
you you running in contact with all
different people
you know and um they're they deceive you
you know they they pretend to be one way
and then they're another way you know
and when you get into that car you don't
know
if you're gonna live or die you know and
that's the chance that you have to take
um just to just to get to maintain your
habit
have you worked with dance before pardon
have you worked with tim's before
um well this one guy
it just didn't make any sense for me to
give him my money
he tried to and then he was real abusive
and i see what he did to the other girls
so i got out real fast
and then he was talking about taking me
to another state and all this stuff and
wanted his friend a drug he had seen him
drug one of the girls and i just got out
i left and i never came back i was
really scared for my life so
that was one thing i said i'll never
work for a pimp you know and um
i just do my thing you know i get out
there i make my money i pray before i
get in the car
and i pray to god that i make it out you
know it's a
it's a wild life what do you think that
keeps you
in that life is it is there something in
your childhood that maybe
kind of makes that acceptable and even
makes you makes you comfortable with it
or
because there's other options for you
yeah well when you're using drugs the
drugs is
it's a fast way of getting money you
know and when you're using you have to
you have to
you don't have time to be trying to do
the drugs drive the prostitution not the
other way around
it well it works both ways it works both
ways
it works both ways it really does um
i don't like laying up having you know
doing stuff for money and stuff but
it's fast money you get in you get out
and you go on about your business
you know and um yeah
it says this is the man
the prostitution life is really really
is scary
you know sometimes you know they'll put
the word out like oh it's this man out
here that's trying to rape girls or
this is gross man out here trying to
trying to uh
kidnap girls or whatever you have to
really like have your eyes and ears open
you know and your visual all on so you
can
pretty much if the description that they
give you you got to go off of that
you don't have no other way to know who
that person is
you know so it's just a lot of prayer
basically your intuition
intuition yes all of that you know
and then i don't date black guys i hear
that a lot i don't i don't date black
guys because
uh they're they're very um they're very
abusive
you know they're um they're stillers
they they take take take you know and
and nine times 10 they want to act like
uh
that you're not worth you know whatever
you say whatever i say my price is i
want that
i don't want you to try to down talk me
or try to give me what you want me to
have
no it doesn't work like that you know
you give me what i want or i'm out
so that's what we i've learned to not
date black men because they
they're really um they're really shady
and
your drug is uh crack big pardon what is
your drug
correct right yes how did that start for
you
um like i said was being uh i got
molested at six
you know i blocked it out you know and
then um when i was like 16 that's when
um
everything came back and i just didn't
want to feel it just to want to think
and somebody turned me on to crack and
it was just a
high undescribable high i've never
experienced before
you know and then from there it just led
to a life of crime
and you know prostitution and just
all of that going to jail you know i'm
not proud of it but
it goes with the territory
is it difficult to be around all these
people that are
up to no good you know from the tricks
to the other girls to the cops to the
attempts to everybody um yeah it just
just seems like it would be a hard
environment
it is a hard environment but you got to
pick and choose your battles
you know so a lot of people i don't mess
with because i know who they are or what
they do or
you know what they're known to do i just
separate myself from that
you know because i still got all my
teeth throughout my mouth you know i
don't want to
wear black eyes and you know be beat up
or
be getting robbed or i don't want to do
any of that so i just
i really like stay to myself and just do
my own thing
you work figaro yeah
do you have kids no they were married
no you didn't love no never never
love my money love myself
i've heard that before does your family
know you do this
uh no uh well they probably suspect but
they never like
actually seen they might know now
yeah wow
and it gets you depressed sometimes i'm
sure they parties gets you depressed
sometimes
yeah it's this yeah because this is it's
not a
life that you that this is not what i um
as a child said oh i just wanted to go
up and be a prostitute that's not what
was in the in the plan
you know what would you dream about i
wanted to be a nurse
you know i wanted to be a nurse i love
helping people i'm
i have a carry heart that's why i have
to separate myself from people because
um they'll hurt your feelings you know
you'll be doing stuff out the kindness
of your heart and
you do stuff with good intentions and
then i'll take that for granted
so i've learned in this life that you
just gotta say no and separate yourself
or you would get hurt mentally
physically and emotionally
and the interactions that you have with
guys who pick you up
you just do you actually like any of
these guys are you just tolerating them
i just tolerate them for the moment
you know i tolerate them from mama yeah
um i work for the world but
um since they have the cell phones i
work a lot off my cell phone now
you know where i don't have to be in the
streets and do that and i have a lot of
regular jobs that
i uh that i deal with you know
how many guys you turn down that that
will approach you on the street
oh wow um where you just get bad you get
a bad feeling i get that intuition yeah
i i work out with vibes
you know i work out for vibes i work off
of my intuition
what so what kind of behaviors or
appearances do you look for that
um other than being a person that um
uh that's too anxious
you know what i mean or just just want
to ride by right by right by and just be
you know i don't know i don't want to do
that i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna date you if you do that
you know and it's really dangerous and
it'll be 2020
because everybody's on something you
know everybody's on some kind of
substance
you never know who's on what you never
know what that devil tell them to do
you know so i just try to follow my
insta my
intuition my instincts and my uh first
mind
you know are you saving money doing this
um
i have but just just surviving yeah
surviving
he comes and he goes
what regrets do you have in your life um
i regret in picking up that pipe
i regret that because it have it has
couldn't
learn it has controlled my life you know
in more ways than one
i've done things that i'm not proud of
you know so that's what i really regret
uh
using drugs and not going to finish
school and not
uh finishing out my dreams the things
that i want to do
what do you think most people don't
understand about drug addiction
uh because there's an outsider listening
to your story you'd be like well no put
the crack pipe down and get a job
you have to respect it people don't
understand it you gotta respect if you
don't respect it it'll smoke you
you know and you'll be living in on skit
road and you'll be
you know because your mind once your
mind goes your body gonna follow
so you have to respect what you're doing
you have to respect the gang it's not
like you're not intelligent enough to
figure out that this is bad for you you
know
damn well yeah of course i didn't it's
just very difficult
to get out for even somebody who's
logical and sensible like yourself yeah
just stop stop yeah it is it's a jones
it's a monkey on your back have you been
clean before
uh no never how old do you know
how what how old are you how old am i
i'm 24. you 24.
i'm not sure about 24. but i'll i'll let
you slide on that
does this kind of work
how does it affect your self-esteem does
it build it up or tear down or do both
oh
my self-esteem is out the roof
it really is my self-esteem is like over
the top
people they were like oh you think
you're bougie no i'm glad you feel like
that but
i need a hundred more haters like you by
the end of the year
yeah it's over the top uh i pretty much
don't let
anybody anything get me down you know
this this kind of work is not for every
girl right
no of course not you got to be strong
you got to have tough skin
you really do all the strong survive out
here
you know you don't have tough skin and
don't let you you have to be
um uh you have to let your yes be oh yes
you know no but you'll know it can't be
no in betweens and no gray areas
because if you if you if they see any
kind of weakness
or gray areas they'll walk all over you
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
your years of doing this
oh wow the craziest thing i've seen
um one girl get her her neck slashed
by her pimp for not giving up the money
she stashed the money in a condom in her
[ __ ]
he slashed her throat
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
the most important lesson that i've
learned is to um
never give up on your self-worth never
give up
i know i'm worth more than what i'm i'm
out here doing
but at the same time is um
i have to stay i have to say positive
you know what i mean i want to live you
know i try not to let no negativity
because when you you let negativity and
it's gonna follow you you know you're
not gonna
not even get what you you came you
sought out to do because you have all
these negative vibes that's going on
with you so
just trying to stay positive and just
try to stay true to who i am true true
to me
what advice would you give to a young
girl just thinking of doing something
like this
um i would give her if i stay in school
stay in school learn everything you can
learn they can't take away what you know
they can put you anywhere anywhere
in the united states but they cannot
take away what you know
so learn all you can and stay in school
and
um be uh follow your dreams
you know don't let don't get caught up
in a in a shuffle in a buffalo of
everyday living you know of using drugs
and um
and uh prostitution and
it's just it's not worth it it's not
worth it especially if you don't have
any tough skin
it really isn't it's not worth it how is
how is doing this kind of work for all
these years
affected your view on men oh it's it's
affected it it has i don't know how to
love
i've never been in love i don't know if
i ever want to be in love
do you respect men less because of what
you learned um
no i respect them i respect them equally
because at the end of the day i can't
whoop a man
i can't beat a man up you know so i stay
in my lane
i stand by lane and maintain maintain a
lady at all times
because you put yourself in a certain
situation or a certain predicament
a man a man would beat you like a dog
beat you like another man
you know so i just try to you know
stay in my lane you know maintain to be
a lady at all times
all right john well thank you so much
for sharing your story you're so welcome
i wish you the best of luck out there be
careful thank you
thank you very much
you